hey youtubers it's Charlie this week on
Walking Dead we got a deep look into
Abraham's group some big teasers for
Washington DC and sanctuary and it was
all candy bars comic books and easy
cheese quick shout out for this week's
giveaway in case you're finding me for
the first time I typically select a
subscriber from the comments at random
to give a $20 Amazon gift card to I'll
be announcing who that person is in my
Q&A video tomorrow don't worry there'll
be a link to that at the end of this
video but what I'm gonna do is my top 5
WTF moments then I'll do my review and
list some of the biggest questions I had
after the episode careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen it yet but number 5
smiley face Abraham luckiest man in the
world for people who haven't read the
comic book this scene was a crash course
in Abraham he's got a plan just like the
governor but despite all the smiley face
Walker smashing the tone of the moment
and tears reaction were fairly positive
so I feel like the writers want us to
trust him there were a couple moments
later in the episode that raised some
major red flags but I'll talk about them
in a sec number 4 candy bars comic books
and crazy cheese this was all about me
Sean and Karl getting reacquainted be
shown to starting to open up a lot more
about her past and Karl has grown up or
at least tried to grow up really fast in
the last couple of episodes so they're
really different people than they were a
couple of weeks ago it's a good
opportunity for us to get a lot of me
show and backstory
she's been pacing herself on how much
she reveals but I love the bond that she
and Carl have she's revealing things to
him that she's never told anyone they're
best friends like Rick wants but I think
she also thinks of him as kind of like a
little brother their scenes are the
Welcome aspirin pill to the scenes of
Rick and Karla's yelling at each other
number three who the eff is downstairs I
got a strong hunter's vibe but since no
one got thrown on the grill I think they
were just supposed to be a random
survivors albeit really murdering
randoms there are enough WTF moments
with Rick in the house that I actually
separated the most notable ones the
first one being their arrival and Rick
darting under the bed
anyone who has hidden under a bed from
someone understands what it's like when
a pair of feet just walk up number two
my bed now jackoff as funny as the
jackoff line was I was right there under
the bed with Rick I actually thought
that he was going to have to pinch that
guy's nose shut in order to keep from
being discovered he was still breathing
in jackoff number one probably would
have straight-up killed Rick if he found
out later he followed through and killed
one of the other
but then the tension was all about that
person turning which he eventually did I
really liked the twist of Rick being
able to use that in order to escape with
me Schon and Karl and my number one
moment the fate of the human race
depends on dr. mullet Abraham teases us
that because Eugene might know what
caused the outbreak potentially there's
a cure this has been one of the biggest
ongoing questions of the comic book and
the TV show I've always thought that the
virus was a red herring something that
didn't really matter I think the real
story of Walking Dead is what happens to
these regular people after making it
about a cure would completely changed
the show in a bad way everyone's focus
would be about the solution and it's
really supposed to be a drama about
people now it's your turn let me know
what was your biggest WTF moment from
the episode and do you think that Robert
Kirkman or anyone on the show should
reveal an actual here at some point
overall I love the deep look into
Abraham's group the tease for Washington
DC bricks game of hide and seek and the
continuing sanctuary teasers I'm gonna
give the episode a solid b-plus just
because all of the new elements that
Abraham's group introduced to the story
and that hide and seek pacing things
would go from super intense like Rick's
staring into those guys eyes underneath
the bed and then they're just easy
breezy crazy choosing their way down the
railroad tracks
I love the dynamic of Rick's group now
that me shown is with them it just gives
the writers opportunities for more
comedy and have those classic family
breakfast type moments Rick and Carl
might be doing better but I still see a
lot of tension between them I feel like
most of that tension is coming from baby
Judith now so here are a couple really
big questions that I had during the
episode that we can try and answer in
the comments
one is that crook road sign meant to
imply that Abraham is a crook
- does Karl's character genuinely hate
soy milk or where the writers just
trolling 3 when are they going to run
into baby Judith quick side note though
both tyreese's group and Rick's group
are heading towards sanctuary so they'll
probably get there before the end of the
season for what was up with that
mutilated painting was it just meant to
juxtapose the nice-looking one of the
rabbits I actually thought that the
rabbit painting was a visual mirror to
Lizzy killing the rabbits in episode 10
5 is Eugene or dr. mullet as Twitter
likes to call him autistic or just
really clumsy despite looking like a
redneck I'm totally willing to believe
that he's a real bill scientist who can
help but the whole clumsy rifle scene
kind of says dude
trust anything you hear about this man
and six what is Abraham trying to atone
for Tara totally calls him out on the DC
mission I think that it's pretty clear
he did something during Iraq or
Afghanistan that he wants to balance out
so let's try and discuss a PHY some of
those questions as well as some of the
WTF moments in the comments it's gonna
be a while before the show gives us
explicit answers because next week we're
back to Daryl and Beth and it does not
look like things are getting better for
them
remember I'm selecting one random
subscriber from the comments on this
video to give that gift card too I'll
announce who that is in the Q&A video
tomorrow right now click here to get
last week's episode and click here to
get that Q&A video thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow high
fives